does it hurt
it's dying
did we have to say goodbye it's okay
just give her a hug all right there's
been times where our favorite characters
from some of our most treasured shows
have to part ways often times this isn't
just emotional for the actors on the
show but emotional for the audience as
well whether it be a thematic decision
or the stars themselves pursuing
opportunities these character departures
broke our hearts
[Music]
gary oldman brilliantly portrayed the
fan favorite character sirius black in
the harry potter films and his
character's passing turned out to be
quite emotional black's final moments
had the film knocked into the veil by
his own cousin bellatrix lestrange which
transported him to the afterlife oldman
apparently wasn't too thrilled about his
character being killed off and the death
scene turned out to be quite the
emotional one with radcliffe not knowing
whether he'd get to work with oldman
again thankfully oldman was able to
return as the character for a brief
scene in the final film harry potter and
the deathly hallows part two
and dobby has come to save harry potter
perhaps one of the most emotional
character departures in the harry potter
franchise wasn't actually a human
character but instead dobby the house
elf at the end of harry potter and the
deathly hallows part one
after sacrificing his life for harry by
taking a knife in the chest thrown by
bellatrix lestrange the house elf passes
in harry's arms fans were understandably
outraged by the character's departure
which led the series creator jk rowling
to eventually apologize for killing off
the character it's that anniversary
again this year i apologize for killing
someone who didn't die during hashtag
battle of hogwarts but who laid down his
life to save the people who'd win it i
refer of course to dobby the house elf
don't be afraid
grogus aka baby yoda's departure in the
season two finale of the mandalorian had
fans feeling a wide range of emotions as
the iconic luke skywalker comes to pick
up the child from mando leading to a
tearful goodbye while grogu's departure
had been expected since it had been the
titular character's goal to give him to
the jedi it didn't make their goodbye
any less emotional
looking back on it i just remember the
good stuff marvel fans knew that robert
downey jr couldn't play tony stark
forever but that didn't stop the
waterworks from coming during the final
act of avengers end game downey's
contracts became more and more expensive
as the mcu moved forward and the
acclaimed actor wanted to pursue other
roles in his career downey didn't have
any regrets about departing the highly
successful franchise we had to get off
we opted to and knew it was part of the
job to get off the bus while it rolled
on to other destinations there's
something very sobering about it
chris evans steve rogers is one of the
most cherished characters in the mcu
which led to his departure at the ending
of endgame to be heartbreaking but also
emotionally satisfying evans had
initially turned down the role multiple
times before giving in to marvel's
tactics which he is still very thankful
for evans felt that roger's ending an
end game was satisfying and said that
it'd be a shame to sour his ark if he
were to return
nairobi was easily one of the most
popular characters on the netflix series
money heist but the character's brutal
death left many fans feeling conflicted
creator of the series jesus call menard
defended the character's departure
claiming that nairobi would have had a
hard time fitting into the series fifth
season particularly because the final
season was all about direct
confrontation and the concept didn't fit
with the character komenaro also felt
that nairobi's passing would help
inspire the show's other lead characters
and give them the motivation they needed
in the final season
honestly what can you say about a 19
year old who dies
after the untimely death of cory
monteith ryan murphy and the producers
of the hit series glee struggled with
how they would retire his character of
finn hudson instead of simply just
having the character be recast murphy
and his team decided to have the
character of finn pass on while
initially the character was planned to
succumb to a drug overdose the glee team
decided to take a more ambiguous route
and not name the cause of death of finn
and instead have the season five episode
the quarterback as a tribute to both the
star and the character
it's okay
you're okay
out of all the deaths in the hunger
games one of the most devastating is the
death of rue in the second act of the
hunger games after marvel strikes her
down with a spear the death has always
stuck out as a pivotal moment in the
series and is certainly one that carries
a lot of emotion jack quade the actor
behind marvel felt bad about the fact
that he was the one who killed the
character played by amandla stenberg in
all fairness i met my demise very
quickly afterwards i was brainwashed by
my luxurious district 1 upbringing but
yes incredibly sorry he died a hero luke
perry's passing was one that caught many
across the industry by surprise
including the creators and the cast of
riverdale where perry starred as
archie's father fred andrews instead of
recasting the character series creator
roberto aguirre sakasa decided to make
an episode that would serve as a tribute
to both the character and perry one
where it would shed the camp and to
become more grounded even perry's old
beverly hills 90210 co-star shannon
doherty had a guest spot on the episode
uh i'm just paying my respects in order
to pay tribute to her late friend
this is gonna feel so good getting this
thing off my chest
potentially the biggest example of a
major star parting ways with their tv
show was steve carell when he left the
hit series the office corral's michael
scott ended up leaving the scranton
office of dunder mifflin to be with his
fiancee holly as she moved back to
colorado to take care of her ailing
parents initially things were unclear on
why carell left the series with many
believing that corel made the decision
as his contract was about to expire but
the truth was that he planned on
renewing his contract but the producers
of the show never called him back the
character's departure received a
multi-episode arc and is highlighted as
the series at some of its most emotional
i hope i make you proud before becoming
the superstar childish gambino that he's
known as today one of the first roles
donald glover ever played was troy
barnes on the nbc series community
because of rising turmoil behind the
scenes of the show along with the firing
of showrunner dan harmon glover decided
to part ways with the series but not
before being asked to come back for a
few episodes so his character could have
a proper send-off troy's departure was
written so that he had the opportunity
to sail around the world but at the cost
of leaving his friends at greendale
community college behind what makes the
scene the most emotional was troy's
final hug with danny pootie's abed who
he shared a very close and unbreakable
bond with
well
i'll see you around
after playing the character of fiona
gallagher for nine seasons on the hit
series shameless emmy rossum who played
fiona gallagher opted to leave the
series to pursue new roles in her career
fiona's final arc in the series was a
turbulent one from recovering from
alcoholism and getting herself together
before leaving her family behind and
finally doing something for herself
instead of just for her father while
there were initially plans for the
character of fiona to return for the
series 11th and final season
complications with the pandemic deterred
that from happening
don't be okay
hugh jackman had the honor of donning
the wolverine claws for 17 years and it
got to a certain point where it's hard
to see any other actor taking on that
role jackman and director james mangold
were initially going back and forth on
whether or not to kill off the iconic
character at the end of logan but
ultimately came to the realization that
it was only appropriate for the
character to pass on but the reason the
choice was at our feet was because you
needed this sense of closure you needed
some sense of an ending if you were
going to end if you were dealing with
the legacy of hugh's many performances
and many films and trying to set this
apart in some definitive way
the way you said it it's like goodbye
say something else
paul walker's tragic passing during a
break from filming furious 7 clearly had
an effect on the cast and crew behind
the fast and furious franchise knowing
that it would never be the same again
instead of killing the character of
brian o'connor off the filmmakers behind
the seventh entry opted to use the film
to retire the character the film ends
with a moving send-off of the character
of brian leaving the world of racing
cars and saving the world to be with his
family
i caught the last flight out
many fans of that 70s show felt that the
beloved sitcom lost its way when topher
grace's eric forman departed the show to
study abroad in africa in reality grace
had left the series to focus on building
his career as a movie star hoping that
it would take his career to new heights
as he starred in films like spider-man 3
as the villainous venom grace did end up
returning to the show for the finale but
his initial absence was certainly felt
even with character departures becoming
increasingly common in our favorite
movie franchises and tv shows it doesn't
make it any less emotional regardless of
whether or not the departure was planned
what character departure made you the
most emotional